minister your excellency thank you very
much for talking to sky news um
first of all can i just get your sense
of what you hope
this g20 will achieve it's taking place
under difficult circumstances
different circumstances what do you hope
that it will achieve
presidency was based on themes that deal
with empowering our
populations in particular youth and
women uh
protecting our planet whatever in
all facets what that means and also
ensuring that we have
better international cooperation
multilateralism in order to deal with
the challenges the world's faces and i
think the
i believe that the pandemic has proven
that unless we all work together
all of us will lose and that the more we
work together the more effective we are
in dealing with challenges such as this
pandemic
and also in the future other challenges
that we may face
i was going to pick up on on precisely
that because i think coronavirus
has proved has it not how the world has
failed to work together i mean
organizations and like the g20 groupings
like the g20
this is these are just the sorts of
forums
that should be coming together with a
global crisis like this
have we seen an extraordinary global
failure
in terms of dealing with coronavirus i i
don't believe so i think the
the the pandemic was unprecedented what
has the g20 done and the world done in
this
they have spent almost 20 billion
dollars working on vaccines
they have spent 11 trillion dollars to
stabilize
the global economy they have spent 230
billion dollars in order to
restructure loans for poorer countries
so what we're seeing is we're seeing
a an event that has brought the world
closer together
and our hope is that when this pandemic
is over and it will be over
that the lessons learned from this
pandemic is that by working together we
can achieve a lot more than by working
against each other i think with the
vaccine you're absolutely correct we
have to agree on
uh whether it is it is safe what the
protocols for administrating it
is and most importantly where the
priority goes because you don't want the
wealthy countries
to be able to vaccinate their people and
the poorer countries
left in the dark when will you bring the
war in yemen to an end
we wish that the war in yemen never
started it was forced on us by the
houthis when they took over the
legitimate government of yemen
and imprisoned its president and
destroyed its emerging democracy
i had the organization that's allied
with iran and hezbollah
and we were not going to allow yemen to
be taken over by such an organization
we intervened at the request of the
legitimate government in accordance with
u.n
article 51 of the u.n charter we said
from day one that there is no military
solution has to be a
political solution we have supported
every political initiative by every u.n
special envoy
we have engaged in confidence building
measures we have provided gestures six
months
or so ago we announced the ceasefire
unilaterally
we provided exchange of prisoners but
every time there seems to be an
agreement or an understanding
the houthis renegot that's the challenge
that we have in yemen and i think it's
important that the international
community put pressure
on the hussein order to cause them to
come to the negotiating table and reach
a political settlement
but the un is now accusing you
and the houthis of war crimes both sides
i mean this has been going on
for six years we've it's it's
for so long been talked about as the
world's worst humanitarian crisis it's
horrific
what's going on there and all we hear
from you with respect
and those on the other side is just
words when is the war going to be
brought to an end it is in your power to
bring it to an end
you can't stop a war um unless you have
a political settlement we have reduced
military operations substantially
we don't launch ballistic missiles at
towns and villages against civilians
we don't employ child soldiers with boys
who are eight nine and ten years old
that's what the houthis do
the houthis stop humanitarian assistance
from reaching people they stop
the world fruit program from
distributing food they stop the world
health organization from
distributing cholera vaccine they robbed
the central bank they wrapped the
phone company they robbed the income
from the port of fredera
and yet nobody seems to be blaming them
it's tragic that this war has gone on
for so long
yemen is our neighbor we want yemen to
prosper and to be stable
the war in afghanistan took the united
states and its coalition partners 19
years and it's still not over
the war against daesh in syria and iraq
started
involves more than 70 of the world's
greatest powers and it's been going on
now for five years or six years
and it hasn't ended yet so i'm not
saying
that the war in yemen that that minister
you saying that this war i mean
you're equating it to afghanistan are
you saying this one could go on for many
many more years
i hope not and we're trying our best to
try to put it to an end very quickly
back to the g20 a very exciting moment
for saudi arabia and a moment of hope
and
looking forward to the future but at the
same time
it is clear from what we've heard over
the past few days that that human rights
issues are
uh still at the fore when when it comes
to saudi arabia i want to talk briefly
about lujanat
al al-hathoul she is still in prison
when will she be released and why is she
in prison in the first place
she will be released when the court when
the legal process plays out
for decisions being her case is being
reviewed by the courts
and then once she's released then she
will either be punished or she'll be
released it's up to the courts
the uh the decision to uh
detain her had to do with national
security shares and not with the
advocating the right to women to drive
which every woman in saudi arabia
that advocated uh to to drive would be
put in jail then half the ladies in
saudi arabia would be
detained by now why is she a national
security issue
has to do with national security it has
to do with taking
funds from foreign powers and giving
them to hostile powers it has to do with
trying to recruit people in sensitive
position in order to
obtain sensitive documents and give them
to powers hostile to the kingdom of
saudi arabia
this is what the public prosecutor said
when the when the detention was made and
i believe that the
rest of the of the evidence will be made
will be made public i expect by the
court once the verdict is rendered
because under our system
the ports generally uh provide the
details
of the of the charges after a verdict is
rendered but she's not been given access
to
to her family she's not able to make
phone calls there are allegations of
various forms of abuse of her in prison
she's currently i believe
uh on hunger strike as a consequence of
all this i mean just
broadly sir as as a minister this
doesn't look good for saudi arabia does
it
this is a woman's right to female rights
activist
on what basis do you say that she wasn't
granted all these rights because i
believe that
our our security officials dispute that
in terms of no
contact and in terms of hunger strike
and in terms of abuse and in terms of
this issue was taken very seriously by
the leadership of my country
and his majesty and the crompton's
ordered investigation into the issue the
allegations of abuse of torture
and so on what basis do people say this
we
i as far as i know this is not correct
she is detained
like other detainees she is facing trial
and when the trial
is over she will be found guilty or
found it isn't it's up to the courts
and when she if she should be found
guilty i would expect
that in generally this is what the
courts do is that the evidence will be
made available
can i invite you to reflect a little on
the on the trump presidency
uh it is over four years um
how how does how will saudi arabia
remember
four years of donald trump well
technically it's not over it's another
two months
but um the the kingdom of saudi arabia
has a bipartisan relationship with the
united states our relationship was
started between king abdulaziz
and franklin delano roosevelt a democrat
it continues continued through every
democratic and republican administration
and it has grown stronger and stronger
with each decade i believe that the
united states
i don't believe i know the united states
has interests around the globe saudi
arabia has interests around the globe
our interests are aligned and those
interests are not going to change
and we look forward to working with any
american administration
to further those interests the interests
might not change but the strategy
of a biden administration might be
somewhat different i mean
he he is going to have a different
relationship
with saudi arabia in the same way that
he's going to have a different
relationship
perhaps a less warm relationship with
israel for example i mean
how do you expect the next four years to
differ from the last
and are you worried about them i believe
president
elect biden was in the senate for 35
years
and he was vice president for eight
years he has tremendous experience he
knows the world
i and everybody i believe that he's
going to a point in his administration
are people that
we are likely familiar with and have
worked with
uh extensively over the years so i'm not
concerned about the
change in the american position or
american policy um
what's what happens is from one
administration to the other
the articulation might differ might
differ but the implementation really
doesn't
i wonder what your view is on on on the
fact that donald trump is insisting he
actually won the election
and the idea of a president-elect biden
is is
is not true he is still and will remain
the president
i said as a foreign official
i don't believe it makes sense for me to
comment on the
internal deliberations of the united
states and especially when it comes to
elections with constitutional matters i
will leave that to my friends in the
united states to result
so you're fully expecting a a president
biden
come january the 20th next year we will
see i can't like i said
once once the election is certified we
will know who the president is